Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see James, Naomi, Marcus, Sarah. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
The insights tool has been posting to #insights for a month. Let's review whether it's measuring the right things or just generating noise.
Exactly.
My test is whether it respects that questions are participation. Last week it flagged me as high-participation in the advisory sync even though I mostly asked questions.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Okay, works for me.
So it passed my test — it didn't score me low for not asserting.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Just flagging that this touches the manifest schema and validator, so loop me in when it firms up.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Okay, works for me.
It correctly stopped flagging me as 'silent.' Because it cross-references chat and the round-robin turns, it sees my contribution now. In Q2 it would have scored me near zero and been wrong.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the backend capability model and the provenance schema anyway.
Makes sense to me.
That's fair.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
That's fair.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Good point — let's do that.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Agreed, let's capture it.
That tracks.
It caught that Lily and I almost duplicated the caching work in July, before we'd written a line. The people-matching is the most useful part.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Makes sense to me.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Sure, I can own that.
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
Okay, works for me.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That's fair.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Right, that's what I meant.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Yeah, exactly.
Makes sense to me.
Agreed, let's capture it.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
That tracks.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Good — next.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
Right, that's what I meant.
How does this interact with the manifest schema and validator, if at all?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
I'll walk through this top to bottom, stop me if anything's unclear.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Makes sense to me.
One miss: it over-flagged a quiet planning week as disengagement. We tuned the threshold. I changed my mind on always-on nudging — it needs a quiet mode.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
That's fair.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Yeah, exactly.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Good point — let's do that.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Agreed.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Good point — let's do that.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Makes sense to me.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Just flagging that this touches community review and the advisory process, so loop me in when it firms up.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Makes sense to me.
Let's confirm in the channel.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Okay, works for me.
Agreed, and that's a real limitation to write down, not paper over. But net, it's doing the job. Ship the district rollout.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Let's confirm in the channel.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
Good point — let's do that.
Sorry, can you say that last part again? You cut out for a second.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Sure — one sec.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That's fair.
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Quick clarifier — who owns the follow-up here, and by when?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on the manifest schema and validator?
One thing: how does this affect the the backend capability model and the provenance schema timeline?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
James has the follow-up on community review and the advisory process — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Naomi has the follow-up on the manifest schema and validator — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.